Another variation is
that overflow occurs.
So, by overflow we mean,
we write it to beyond the point that
this variable getting written,
has been allocated space.
So, I said data also gets allocated
on the heap in a program.
So long-lived data, for
example, global variables, and
so on, get stored on the heap.
So, one crucial difference
between the heap and
stack is that heap does
not have a return address.
So, you cannot hijack the control
flow of the program, and
take it some place where
you have your own codes, or
a library function, or
return-to-lib kind of attacks.
But in the heap we do
have function pointers
depending on what kind of language,
and how they implemented and so on.
So data can be these tables
of function pointers.
And there you can modify
a function pointer, and
by doing that you can transfer control,
it's actually a lot harder than
the stack buffer overflows
we were are talking about.
Heap overflows require sort of more
sophisticated in some sense and require
more work, but you can by modifying,
figuring out where a certain function
is, and modifying the function pointer,
you can transfer control to somewhere
else where this new address that you
place in the function pointer points to.
So heap overflow is,
again, we're corrupting memory
in some sense as we did before,
but this happens to be memory that is
in the heap part of the address space.